two other quick things to mention here
this is from the daily mail it says two
women in new jersey's only all-women's
prison have both fallen pregnant after
having sex with transgender inmates
the pregnant women who were not
identified are housed at the embattled
edna mahan
correctional facility in clinton which
new jersey governor
announced plans to close last year
prison bosses said that in both
instances the sex was consensual
it is unclear if the women had sex with
the same transgender inmate or if it was
two different inmates
so already we have we need a snopes fact
check here well not a snopes fact check
because they're not going to fact-check
something like this but this is not an
all-women's prison apparently
that's kind of cool that's that's uh
that's
that's hard to figure out it's an
all-women's prison and and women are
falling pregnant how does that happen
well because it's not all women's um
edna mahan houses 27 transgender
prisoners
and over 800 women altogether
it is also unclear how far along the two
inmates are and whether they plan to
continue with their respective
pregnancies whether they plan to
continue there's another euphemism for
you um an investigation has been
launched so
there's a women's prison
800 women and they already have almost
30 men in the women's prison
and i can also without without knowing
anything about the the particulars here
and i don't know that i fully even
believe the particulars that we're being
told
like we're just told that the sex was
consensual i mean maybe it was
but listen there's no reason to believe
that whatsoever
you're taking violent criminal men
oftentimes like rapists and sex
offenders
who are in prison as men and then one
day say you know what i'm actually a
woman
and they're they're sexually attracted
to women and so this is all just just
kind of a happy coincidence
that now they get to be housed with
women
uh you're taking them you're locking
them into cages
with actual women
and then
if a woman
becomes pregnant in fact some of the
headlines there was one headline it
might have been in the daily mail or one
of these other outlets it said that uh
two women have fallen pregnant
at a women's prison they've fallen
pregnant
yeah what are they falling on exactly
that's not that that's not something
that's a that's something that happens
after a particular act now whether that
act was consensual that's my point is
there's no reason to believe that
um
because we are not going to be told
if a trans male rapes a female inmate
that information is not going to make it
to us through any official channels they
would never tell us that
i mean and even if it was supposedly on
the surface consensual
when you when you put a woman
in a in in a prison cell
with a violent dangerous man
and the woman quote chooses to have sex
with the man
is is that actually consent is there a
real choice there
i mean we've been told by the metoo
movement that
um if a woman chooses to have sex with
her boss that it's not really a choice
there's not really any consent there
or not as much consent as there should
be because of the power power dynamics
at play
so you're a woman locked in a cell
with a man who could overpower you at
any moment
and who is sexually attracted to females
and you have sex with them is that is is
it even a choice
or is it something these women are doing
just out of self-preservation
so i don't no matter how you slice i'm
not sure how you can even call it
consensual
and if they've got 30 male prisoners in
in a in this one women's prison in new
jersey
um
this is this we're talking about
hundreds if not thousands of men who are
in women's prisons right now
and again they're they're violent and
dangerous that's why they're in prison
so as i've been saying for a long time
this is um
i i guarantee you
there is right now an epidemic of sexual
assaults by men against women in women's
prisons and it's happening right now and
we will we will never be told about it
though
because these women have no way of
telling us
and of course the metoo movement is uh
conspicuously silent about the whole
thing well i hope you enjoyed that clip
from the matt wall show if you did go
ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content